[Music]
[Applause]
smooth segway to sean casey the mlb
network analyst three-time nhl or nlstar
he's known as the mayor and nobody ever
booed sean casey when he played did they
no i got when i got thrown off from left
i got booed all detroit was booming 60
thousand were like all right get out of
here
so one time i really got booed bad when
you got thrown out from left field at
first base
you got booed
i got booed so bad i literally was like
running back i was running back to the
dugout like oh showering of booze oh man
this is unbelievable i've never been hit
with so many booze in my life
did you get boo like does booing help
or hurt um
well you know what you know what i
my in 1999 i was having a really good
year we were coming down the stretch we
were going to the astrodome to play the
astros
and i remember getting introduced and
that the place booed me and i remember
barry larkin say to me hey man you
finally made it if they're booing you
that means they know who you are and i
was like all right man this is all this
is awesome but what about the home fans
the home fans uh you know what i think
the one thing with the home fans at the
end of the day like people come to see
you play and they want to see you do
well so if they boo you because they're
not happy that maybe this is the only
game they're going through that year and
you're not doing well i understand i can
understand i can understand i've had
that happen before like i've been on a
bad streak with cincinnati a couple
times and was very popular but i got
booed a few times and i understood it
when i freaking grounded into another
double play
okay but what javi baez did and and some
of his teammates like right give me the
logic behind that and doing that to new
york fans
wow i don't know if there's a good logic
as far as doing it to new york fans um
you know i think i i think
i think it was probably not the smartest
of moves just because new york's new
york and like
for me i played in boston you know in
2008 so like boston new york philly
you know listen they're great fans
they're passionate fans they care and
new york and i was talking to cliff
floyd about this the other day he's like
new york fans or some especially mets
fans who are some of the most
knowledgeable fans out there so uh you
know i don't know i know i saw hobbies
you know reaction but as players you
have to understand too you get paid a
lot of money to go out there and perform
and when you don't you're gonna get
booed that's just the nature of the
beast
but when you respond with thumbs down
like it's one thing
yeah you can't do it you just can't do
it i don't know man like you you got to
be able to look at yourself in the
mirror too like and say you know what i
i'm not really playing that well in
these last few games and we are
10 games under 500 or whatever it was in
our last 40 and you know we're not
giving the fans what they want we are
under achieving like so you can't boo
back to to the fans when you're not
getting it done it'd be different if it
was different circumstances but the
bottom line is the mets are under
achieving right now and the fans are
booing i don't think it's okay to boo
back to fans because it just sends a bad
message well it's you know what came
first the chicken or the egg you know
your bad play came before the booing
started if you play well
then they're not going to be booing you
i just never understood and i remember
tino martinez told me that he went from
the yankees to the cardinals and he said
you know i would get booed at yankee
stadium if i wasn't playing well i went
to st louis and they were like hey
you'll get them next time yeah and and
tino said i wanted them to yell at me i
wanted them to boo me like i i needed
that i expected that not like hey that's
okay you're over ten we'll get em next
time tino come on don't worry about it
you're gonna be okay well st louis is
the one place i remember you you make a
diving play on the visiting team you
come up and they're cheering for you
you're like
and i can see like you're right tina
martinez hey you're all right man you're
over your last 27 you'll be better
tomorrow in new york they're like get
out of town you suck you're out of here
could you have played in new york yeah i
think i could have definitely played new
york yeah i could have definitely played
new york especially later in my career
when you start when you start to
understand what it takes to play in
places like that you know my my last
year danny was in boston so and i ended
up hitting well so i always say what was
they always say what was your experience
like in boston i said it was
unbelievable you know i ended up hitting
over 300 and i never got booed so it was
a great thing great experience
what kind of ball player would you be
because you were an average you hit for
average not an average hitter you hit
for average
is there a place in baseball for you
today
oh man i i think
i think i'm my i think a hitter like
myself
would be more appreciated in today's
game just because
you know i and i didn't you know i
didn't strike out a hundred times like i
was gonna i was a 370 on base you know i
was i was i was i was still gonna i was
still gonna hit your doubles i was gonna
hit you some home runs i was gonna drive
in runs so like a guy like me i think
would have been would have there's they
need more guys like me that were good
haters in the game today because the
three true outcomes and just the the
strikeouts how it's just okay to strike
out 200 times nowadays and i just don't
i don't think that's the greatest
product and i also think danny if you go
and look at the at the teams that have
won it in the last few years you know
these teams do have good hitters down up
and down their lineups there are tough
outs in those lineups so yeah do i think
i would do well in today's game sean
casey works for the major league
baseball network three-time national
league all-star
do you think back in the day and you
were probably in the uh the throes of
the steroid uh era in the late 90s like
do you have to make a conscious decision
to say i'm not going to use steroids
i i think so yeah you know what's funny
man i and i mean this sincerely like i
never did steroids and i didn't even
know all the guys were doing it i just i
mean lifting was huge then guys were
huge
and i really think the guys that were
doing it knew knew they all knew they
were like a little club so did i suspect
some guys like a couple guys that i that
would come to spring training like with
30 pounds of muscle and i'm in the off
season with a personal trainer like just
getting after it four or five days a
week doing everything i can i put on
three pounds of muscle and i come into
spring training like what the hell is
this normal you put on three pounds of
muscle and i'm like bro how'd you put on
35 pounds of muscle in four months he's
like oh man i just i was training hard
and had a personal trainer i was like so
did i
i was like you put on 32 more pounds of
muscle than i did you got to be kidding
me
so you know playing in that playing
during that time i think it was a
conscious choice not to do it but
looking back i don't i i think for a lot
of those years i didn't realize how many
guys were doing it because there's
there's the pressure it's not when you
get to the majors but in the minor
leagues and uh you know two guys i know
who were former minor leaguers said if
you don't want to do it
but then you see that somebody else is
doing it and they're going to get a
better chance of getting called up so
it's that peer pressure and the money is
so different when you get called up that
you really have to have that
you know uh
the good angel on your shoulder and the
devil on on your other shoulder and
you're like who am i listening to here
yeah yeah well i think the pressure
you're right the pressure
uh the money nowadays um when you start
to feel that okay the the the playing
field is not fair you know what i mean
that their guys are making it the you
know that are doing steroids they're the
ones making all the money and here i am
in the miners i'm not gonna make it and
i and and what am i gonna do get a pat
on the back and say i didn't do it so i
think there was a real dilemma there for
guys and a lot of guys that did do it
and didn't do it and understandably so
handicap the national league west you
like the giants or the dodgers here down
the street oh man man i tell you what i
just think that
i i the giants have been so awesome what
a story you know and i think they're
really i think they're a really really
good team i mean i just feel like the
dodgers are coming you know they've been
making that run they're a half game back
now pushing hard uh you know adding
scherzer and turner and those guys you
know at the deadline i think has been
huge uh i think that i think the dodgers
overtake the giants uh in september
what do you think about the usage of
shohei ohtani doing double double duty
here
i love it i love it i i think i think
we're seeing who shohei
um really is because when when madden
was like what do you want to do i think
what spring training is like what do you
want to do he's like listen i want to
hit and i want to pitch i don't want to
go back to taking two days off and you
know with kid gloves i think they took
the kid gloves off and they say the
reason you're here is because you're a
once-in-a-generational player no you're
a once-in-a-lifetime player we've never
seen a guy like you like go do it and so
i think the fact that he's doing it he's
built to do what he's doing and i think
that's why
it's been such an unbelievable thing to
see shohei you know do what he's doing
on both sides of the ball well i i like
the story
but i wonder about
long term can he continue to do it does
it take away from i can't imagine and i
saw this at yankee stadium a couple of
months ago where he's got to face the
yankees and they've got to lead off
you you know pitchers spend five days
preparing for a start and he's playing
every single day
and and and just that mental fatigue
that you have it's such a long season
and i
that's what i wonder is it
counterproductive will it be
counterproductive at some point no but i
think he's the biggest thing with a big
leaguer if you talk to anybody it's your
routine hey man what's your routine when
you come to the big leagues hey get a
good routine well shohei since he's
obviously been been a teenager in japan
has got this routine where he could
start every fifth day but also hit every
day i think his routine's just different
than what we know in the states that's
why we've never seen anything like it so
i think he's gonna be able to do it i
really do i think he's got his body
condition and danny if he doesn't then
he picks one of them and he'd be still
one of the best players in baseball on
one side of the ball but to watch him do
this as long as we can man as fans we
got to keep really enjoying it and
saying we've never standing like this
how many hall of famers did you take
deep
uh i think i took a few deep
uh
i don't know do you have the numbers i
don't know maybe like
how about how about 15.
give me the one though that you like you
took deep and you're like that that
picture might be a little
i took i took uh i took um let me see
well one pops into my head i took glavin
deep a few times
um i took i hit really well against
maddox
uh smoltz was pretty nasty
uh let me see randy johnson i never took
deep but i hit him pretty well
uh let me see what other big uh roy
holiday man maybe i didn't go deep in
beds enough i know i hit a lot of them
well but
maybe not i know i got glavin a few
times
um why am i drawing blanks on hall of
famers that i played against but
so maybe two
[Laughter]
you went from 15 to 10 to two
i was like man maybe
there's got to be one more out there
somewhere okay you walk up to the plate
for the first time against randy johnson
yeah
what are you
i i seriously was like
god is this scary like
seriously why walk out there my first
time facing i'll never forget i was in
cincinnati he's with arizona i walk out
he's just got the long mullet you know
just you know 6 11. you know it is so
scary and i get up there and i remember
thinking to myself oh my god that's
randy johnson i got his baseball card
it's unbelievable next you know i was
like bam 100 outside corner i'm like
jesus that's unbelievable wham 100
outside corner and then at 93 mile an
hour slider 93 mile an hour and i'm like
wow i'm in for a dog fight here so i've
never seen anything like this in my
entire life right so i'm like danny i
start battling because you know i didn't
strike out a lot so i get the 2-2 i'm
like i'm not punching out 2-2 foul foul
foul so on this unlike the seventh pitch
randy johnson walks up he gets like 10
feet from the from the freaking uh from
the plate he snatches the ball and looks
at me like
[Laughter]
oh my god i was like i just want to get
the hell out of here i was like so the
next pitch i grounded out and i was
running the first i was like that's the
greatest ground out of my life i just
wanted to be done
[Laughter]
oh it's always great to talk to you man
hope you're well
all right danny great to see you man
thanks for having me on that's sean
casey now you know why he was called the
mayor
the fact that randy johnson's like 10
feet away going
major league baseball network analyst
three-time national golf star uh you can
watch sean across mlb network's
programming plus check out his new
podcast the mayor's
office